Having defined the independent set and
vertex cover problems,
we will now show that vertex cover
is as hard as independent set.
In general, finding a reduction
can be very difficult.
Sometimes however, it can be as simple
as playing around with the definition.
You will notice that in both
these examples here and
in the exercises, the set of
vertices used in the vertex cover
was the complement of the vertices
used in the independent set.
Let's see if we can explain this.
A set S is an independent set
if there are no edges within S.
By within,
I mean that both endpoints are in S.
That's equivalent to saying that
every edge is not within S,
or that every edge is incident on V- S.
A-ha!
But that just says that
V- S is a vertex cover.
So of course the complement
of an independent set
was always a vertex cover and
vice versa.
Thus, we have the observation
that a subset of the vertices S
is an independent set if and
only if V- S is a vertex cover.
As a corollary then, G will contain
an independent set of size at least K,
if and only if it has a vertex
cover of size at most V- K.
The reduction then is
fantastically simple.
Given a graph G and a number K,
the reduction just keeps the same graph
G and
changes K to the number of vertices- K.